Peter we get this decision 470 480 pages
long you look through it and you find
some language here about what could
happen to exclusive economic zones right
what are they what is an exclusive
economic that's where you have it's 200
nautical miles from your Shore in every
direction and it gives you exclusive
rights to fish to drill for oil to do
subsea mineral exploration and it's very
valuable and it's huge the United States
has bigger exclusive economic zone in
terms of square miles of ocean then it
does of dry land in the 50 states so if
that comes into question it's kind of a
big deal I think it's been mostly missed
by the press and it comes into question
why again in this in this long report in
this long decision we're looking at the
Spratly Islands in the in the center I
see what did the tribe you don't have to
say about them and their habitability I
guess the tribunal interpreted what's
called the United Nations Convention on
the law of the sea which has some
language in it which has kind of never
been closely analyzed which says that in
order to claim one of those very
valuable 200-mile nautical mile
exclusion zones the piece of land has to
be habitable build will support human
habitation economic activity and yet
some of the islands or rocks you might
call them they've been claiming this
really I wouldn't call them habitable
and importantly the tribunal said simply
having soldiers or sailors garrisoned on
an anorak does not define habitability
because there's a being supported
entirely by provisions brought in from
outside it has to be able to have fresh
water you know you know maybe cultivate
soil and so what happens the United
States Japan to name two but also many
other countries could find that some of
their islands and rocks are subject to
challenge say by fishermen from other
nations that want to fish there China
has said it's not going to pay attention
to this ruling from this international
court how binding is this when you look
at this language when you see what it
says when you consider in the context of
all this territory around the world
does it have anything in the way of
teeth well first of all it's not legally
binding in that the tribunal was
adjudicating only this one dispute as
arbitrating is the right word between
China and the Philippines but because it
was five most eminent experts on the law
of the sea and because they went to
great lengths to really be exhaustive in
their analysis it probably will have a
big influence on other tribunals and
arbitration panels just lastly he was
about 30 seconds left what industries
might this affect I think of fisheries
fisheries and oil drilling and subsea
mining are the obvious ones because
suddenly all these claims that seemed
pretty secure are up for grabs I think
fisheries is a particularly important
one because the United States has done a
good job of protecting fisheries from
overfishing sure but if they become a
subject to free-for-all then that could
go away and fishes can be depleted more
quickly